- Une vidéo toute simple,
publiée tard mardi,
sur les résaux sociaux.
C'est ainsi que les patineurs
Tessa Virtue et Scott Moir
ont annoncé leur retraite
du patinage artistique.
La voix empreinte d'émotion,
Scott Moir a remercié le public
et expliqué qu'il s'agit du bon
moment pour se retirer,
alors que Tessa et lui aiment
encore leur sport, comme
ils l'ont toujours fait.
La patineuse de 30 ans
a tenu à remercier les amateurs
pour leur soutien indéfectible.
Tous deux natifs de London,
en Ontario, Virtue et Moir
ont remporté leur premier titre
olympique en sol canadien
à Vancouver, en 2010.
Après deux médailles d'argent
à Sotchi, ils avaient annoncé
leur retraite une première fois.
Mais la soif de vaincre les
avait rappelés à la compétition
en 2016, deux ans avant
le rendez-vous de Pyeong Chang.
C'est là qu'ils ont connu
l'apogée de leur carrière
avec le titre par équipe et
une médaille d'or en danse,
gagnée in extremis devant
le couple français
Papadakis-Cizeron.
Les deux patineurs ont fait
leur marque grâce à leur chimie
inégalée sur la glace. Leur
partenariat aura duré 22 ans.
Tessa et Scott salueront
leur public canadien
une dernière fois lors
d'une tournée de spectacles,
avec des passages prévus
à Laval et à Québec,
les 14 et 15 novembre.
Les patineurs promettent
d'appuyer la relève canadienne,
prête à reprendre le flambeau
et à battre tous leurs records,
assurent-ils.
Tessa Virtue poursuivra
sa carrière déjà bien entâmée
dans les médias, elle qui a
multiplié les apparitions
et les engagements publics
depuis son retour